right now
it is estimated anywhere between one
million to about seven or eight million
people in these camps
whether it be the concentration camps
which mainly is for
torturing um indoctrinating um
and creating chinese people because
one of the reasons why actually the main
reason why weaker support in these camps
is because we are not chinese enough
we are not assimilated enough i've
spoken to some former concentration camp
detainees where they've told me that
they were taken um and they were
urinated upon and you think urinated
upon by chinese gods and you know why
they urinated upon
one of these people is because they said
don't you muslims wash yourself before
you pray
wash yourself with this of one kazakh
woman who was working there as a cleaner
who had to strip the women tie them to a
rope on a bed
and clean them up afterwards and these
men were paid
so we see another aspect of the camp as
being turned into
brothels state-sanctioned brothels
they're women being sterilized and women
having forceful abortions they'll put
out numbers of 5-10 people dying
even right now to this day china says
only 5 000 people
in a country of 1.3 billion have died
from covert
whereas in this in the united states
you've got half a million people the
demolition of mosques
demolition of churches now china is not
just against muslims
they are against every religion i
had the honor of interviewing a u.n
human rights lawyer
who was a whistleblower who who she said
with
ample evidence that the un gives names
of uyghurs who are about to speak
um at the human rights councils or the
meetings there to the chinese so that
they can apply pressure
to their families so that those weaker
don't end up speaking at those forums
so the un is giving out their names the
journalists that try
and give an unbiased documentary they
try and
shoot something right their documentary
ends up about how they were followed
by 20 30 20 10 20 black cars
how they are constantly blocked suddenly
so you'll hear this narrative
we we were going to have a visit to that
camp and
there was a mysterious car accident so
they had a block off the road
you know so you'll see this constantly
there is
only one documentary where one uh vice
journalist was able to get in she kind
of had unfitted access but it was still
difficult you know why
because she didn't go there as a
journalist she went there as a tourist
and she sort of spoke to the people and
did this so
and and her documentary if i'm not
mistaken won an
emmy award for her work because she
risked her life doing that
the big question here is if china has
nothing to hide
why don't they they let anybody in i
gain nothing from this
i hope there is no genocide i hope that
there is no organ harvesting
but there is you know if they're hiding
something
something is going on satellite images
don't lie
thousands of witness testimonies don't
lie we compare the jewish holocaust with
the
holocaust now the jews were totally
eradicated in gas chambers
but with china they take it to a level
where
they they benefit off the backs they
benefit
of the slave labor they benefit off the
hair
so you would have really reported about
13 tons
of hair seized at the u.s border
how many people's hair how many people
are in these camps
where you've got 13 tons of hair from
one shipment so they get real hair you
know you can get wigs
with real hair now extensions
it's for profit so they sell it um the
last figure i got from radio free asia
that they were made
in 2019 they made 1.8 billion dollars
just off the hair and we're not talking
about organs yet
there is a situation uh called halal
organ harvesting google it right now
halal organ harvest
the teacher who is teaching and what
they teach is that
that there is no god that there is not
allah and that your god
is [ __ ] and every morning
the the the detainees have to write
letters to xi jinping
essentially it is a dua to xi jinping
to set to repent to xi jinping to make
tawba to xi jinping
xi jinping the leader of china because
that they had
that they had made tawba to allah and
that they would no longer
make tawbah to allah that's you know
what they learned was incorrect and
every time
each class finishes on their way out
they ask them is there allah
what are you going to say in that
situation you're going to say no next
person is there allah
and any person obviously going to say no
but if you hesitate for a second
if you go is that allah in your way you
get beaten for that hesitation
not just cameras outside one inside your
house
two ccp officials living with you
to monitor each and every move to to
manage
oh that person's eating with his right
hand why aren't you eating with your
left hand
these little things like any little
essence of religiosity
is they they can't deal with that if
you've suddenly got your electricity on
in the middle of the night
when last month you didn't ha and it's
the month of ramadan
that guy must be fasting right otherwise
why are you waking up two three four
o'clock in the morning
right how come you suddenly put 20 extra
liters in your car this month compared
to last month so people go
well why don't they protest why don't
they fight why don't they do this why
don't they do that
well you can't fight because you can't
get weapons in
geographically if you look in the
guinness book of records east turkestan
is the furthest geographically away from
open ocean
you've got nine of the 10 highest
mountains surrounding east turkestan
uighurs wanted to escape you can't
escape if you are to escape to the
central asian countries
they'll simply sell you back and make
the biggest brands in the world
pretty much every single brand from your
apple to your knife to your adidas to h
m eighty percent of chinese cotton comes
from east turkestan
so most likely if you're wearing
anything made in china
it most likely came from a weakest line
that's why facebook
twitter youtube vpns
are banned in china why are they banned
because those things
are powerful they will influence the
people
the prophet salallahu he said that when
a person sees wrong or injustice to
change it with their
their actions and if they can't then
change it with their tongue with their
mouth and if they can't then at least
hate in their heart
and what our brother is saying
essentially is
you see you see injustice you see the
wrong or you hear about it
if you can't do anything about it
physically then change it with your
tongue
word of mouth spread the news let people
know make people know send them this
podcast send them
um what's the name of the the talkies
turkistan right on facebook
send them that page send them the
articles on al jazeera send them the
interviews and everything send them this
interview
the interview he did with hamza zorces
pass it along
don't don't hold this information this
is actually an imanna from allah the
fact that you've even heard about this
and now allah is entrusting you to pass
it on to to
make people known just imagine just
imagine you or your family in that
situation
[Music]
this new art facility or this art
institution
opens up but this art institution is
about
a four-hour drive from where you stay
all right now let's say you're trying to
control everything
what's gonna go through your mind as you
start thinking about this
four hours away you start thinking ah
well this is
too far like i don't know if i can do
this
uh let's say you have no form of
transportation like not only is it too
far but i have no form of transportation
um let's say you're just completely busy
with work and
let's say you have kids or let's say you
just have a family where you have to be
the one
to take charge and like uh make the
money for the house or something like
that
bismillah alhamdulillah rasool allah
welcome back to the t3m podcast to all
the new viewers we are the realest
podcast out here so if you aren't
subscribed
consider subscribing and if you are
subscribed then hit the notifications
button
and if you want to go deeper in our
content then check out our patreon
with that being said this is a very
important episode featuring a very
special guest
arslan hidayat is a uyghur rights
activist from sydney australia
and currently resides in bahrain he is
the general secretary of the uyghur
revival association or the ura
a uighur rights organization which sheds
light and raises awareness on the plight
of uyghurs
in chinese occupied east turkestan
arslan also runs talk east turkestan the
most popular facebook page
highlighting the uyghur's plight in the
english language
arslan has been invited to share his
expertise about the weaker's plate
by giving live studio interviews and his
insights on main mainstream
news media outlets like the bbc the
guardian
al jazeera cnn trt world afp and many
others assalamu alaikum and welcome
arslan hidayat
for giving me the opportunity to talk
about um what's
happening to my people under the chinese
regime so thank you
happy birth it is absolutely our
pleasure may allah bless you immensely
so
why don't you start by telling us a bit
of the history of your people the
the beautiful weaker people yeah so uh
the wiga people themselves are a turkic
nation uh so when you think about turks
uh uh we have connections uh say with
present-day turkey
kazakhs uzbeks kyrgyz um
and so that that sort of makes us uh
that's part of the the turkic world
and when we refer to east turkestan it
is the most east
part of geographical turkistan so
geographical turkistan
you would you pretty much be from like
iran azerbaijan
all the way to uh in the east
all the way up to you know even up to
the um
the the great wall of china so uh
with its long history uh the uyghurs
when we say east turkey
it refers to the two governments that
were set up in 1933 1930
1944 but if we go to the actual history
now we can go we can talk about turkish
history for thousands and thousands of
years
but i kind of like to start off with you
know you guys are sort of an
islamic based channel so i sort of like
this to start off with
when the uyghurs accepted islam and
became
the first turkic islamic nation
which then introduced islam to the rest
of the turkic nations uh so if it wasn't
for the uyghurs we wouldn't have things
like arturo
the seljuq empire the ottoman empire um
so the the the king sultan
in 934 so early 10th century accepted
islam
and then for the next couple of hundred
years
spread islam throughout turkistan
and then uyghurs established various
kingdoms during that time and it's not
until we reach about
1759 where where where the chinese
uh and the week is actually clash and
this is the time of the sayyid kingdom
uh also known as the yadkins kingdom
which was invaded by manchu rulers in
1759
and um it becomes or it becomes part
of the chinese empire at the time but
for
the next hundred years or so there are
many revolts there are many battles
and in 62 uh there is a brief
time of independence for the uyghurs in
1862 that is
and during that time um the the wig is
actually give bayer
to the ottoman empire but that is
short-lived and in 76 1876
um the we we have we have further
battles with the manchu empire and
officially
uh the manchu empire annexed the uyghurs
and label the the east turkestan
as what we know now today as the
xinjiang
as xinjiang which literally means new
land new frontier um so this whole idea
about
xinjiang or east turkestan has always
been a part of china is not true
the name itself given to us doesn't
reflect that
so this happens in 1884. once that whole
kind of chinese empire
uh you know china goes through many sort
of empires
you have very various dynasties chinese
nationalists
uh you know dissolve or get rid of
the uh the the manchu empire in 1911
and um now the chinese nationalist is
what is the people that we refer
to right now being the leaders of
present-day taiwan
so that's their ancestry from 1911 to
about 1933 the uyghurs try and get their
independence
away from the chinese nationalists and
in 1933 we established the east
turkestan
islamic republic in the city of kashgar
which which borders with afghanistan now
in turkestan
borders with many countries including
afghanistan kazakhstan kyrgyzstan
tajikistan pakistan india
russia to the north you got mongolia and
obviously
china itself and tibet as well
so the east turkestan islamic republic
is established and then
we lose that country quite quickly
but for the next 10 years we are still
fighting the chinese nationalists and in
1944
uh with the help of the soviets and this
is the time you know about the second
world war
where you know where where borders are
being made and uh
you know lines are being drawn in in the
dirt
and we we we established the east
turkestan republic which is established
in the north in the city of gulja
and yesterday um was its 21st
uh sorry 24th anniversary of the guljah
massacre
people can check that out february 5th
called jamassica
where hundreds were killed and thousands
were arrested
simply for calling for their basic human
rights freedom of religion
freedom of speech so that happened
yesterday
and so that republic 1944
and up until 1949 1949 is when that is
dissolved and taken over by
china chinese communists
um you know during that time you know
during the whole
world war two stage we know that the
united states
bombed the hell out of japan which japan
was occupying
most parts of china together they got
rid of the chinese nationalists so you
can say
that the chinese communist party was
able to take control
not just obvious turkistan but the rest
of china
with the help of the us and their allies
which is quite ironic but in 1955
the wigas are officially given the name
xinjiang
wiga autonomous region and
autonomous by name it's not really
autonomous that was the way so that the
uyghurs no longer revolt
against china or any sort of chinese um
government or regime um
but since then this genocide or this
uh the oppression has been happening
since 49
under china's current regime um
so you had mol zedong and you would have
heard of something called the great leap
forward
where you know many layman people were
sent off to the farms
and anywhere between 45 million to 75
million people were
killed so when we talk about holocaust
china
itself has has gone through many
holocausts and that number um
it you know outweighs what whatever
happens to the jews and right now what's
been happening with the camps
is similar to what happened with the
jewish holocaust so after mao zedong you
had someone called bing xiao ping
which sort of he sort of opened the
the gates to to the west into the world
and
during that time many foreign investors
were able to invest
in china and sort of things like human
rights and that
they were put to one side and during the
80s uh the
west and the world really thought that
you know what we're having issues with
soviet russia you know we want to keep
china
hopefully through these business
dealings and we're able to
sort of democratize
china and make it our allies so we can
you know fight
russia and fight communism as a whole
obviously that did not happen
and you guys famously know that in uh of
the
the lieutenant square massacre which
happened in 1989
again that was pushed to one side and
dealings with china
constantly happened what was interesting
was in 1980
that china introduced the one child
policy and for the minorities the two to
the two child policy so with that
once they started implementing the
two-child policy upon the uyghurs
we had something called the bahrain
massacre where thousands of people were
killed because they were protesting
um against their women being sterilized
and
women having forceful abortions
and when we're talking about abortions
we're not talking about four to six
months
we're talking about women seven eight
months nine months
women who are about to give birth um
being aborted and that practice still
happens
until today where if you're about to
have a third child
um you will be aborted and even if you
did have it have that third child
the parents are likely to go to jail or
be fined
and you know just like with many eastern
uh cultures
arabs turks we have many children we're
not like the west we have one or two
children
it's some four five six seven eight
children so
um that was a very big issue that was a
very big massacre
as i mentioned in 1997
uh there was the goja massacre where
again people were protesting for their
rights
and these sort of massacres happen every
ten or so years
where they'd either be riots or there'd
be a protest
um and and thousands are culled we don't
know
the exact number of people that
disappear with regimes like china
you know they'll put out numbers of five
ten people dying even right now to this
day
china says only five thousand people in
a country of 1.3 billion have died from
covert
whereas in this in the united states
you've got half a million people
so any any sort of numbers that come
from china or the status quo
is uh we know we take it with a grain of
salt
then we have something 12 years later in
2009
um before 2009 you guys obviously know
you know residing in the west um you
know
september 11 happened in 2001 and
in that time you guys understand that um
you know george which said you guys are
really with us or the terrorists and
what china did was at the time they used
the global war on terror to say that
you know what we've got muslims we've
got terrorists
in our in our borders
we're gonna deal with them just like
you're dealing with you know just like
you
just like how you're invading
afghanistan and iraq um
they said we're behind you but you guys
have to be behind us
when we're dealing with our muslim
problem so
so the west in the united states sort of
forgot about the uyghurs
and um saw the league as sort of uh
you know terrorists and you know growing
up i'm 34 this year
that was at a time when i was in high
school i myself experienced
uh discrimination um from my fellow
australians because
uh from the way i look and they knew i
was muslim and yeah
so in 2009
we we see another massacre uh the urumqi
massacre you guys can look this up
again it was a student protest uh
very very similar to what happened in
tiananmen square around 20 years before
um and again uh since then
uh not too long after that the you know
china started its belt and road
initiative which is a trade route which
is supposed to
uh secede whatever um america has going
on
any sort of trade deals in in east asia
or asia as a whole and um from that to
sort of control the region
uh as much as they can before this
project
actually goes into practice we see
modern day 21st century concentration
camps
very much like what happened with the
jews during the jewish jewish holocaust
and sort of leading up to the camps
we saw you know people
who look like myself with a beard who
pray
who people who have hijab people who say
you know at the beginning of this you
did a dua you said salaam to me
those things itself are illegal
muslim names um uh becoming
illegal so for example uh you know
names like muhammad names like fatima
aisha
people had to change the names of their
children um
uh quran's being burned quran's being
translated to reflect
um china's communists uh
their their propaganda line um
uh imams right imam's not just being
killed
imams being forced to dance on the stage
to say that dancing and music is okay
and so
it wasn't just a matter of just killing
and raping and
uh indoctrinating it was denigrating the
religion i've spoken to some
formal concentration camp detainees
where they've told me that
they were taken um and they were
urinated upon and you think urinated
upon by chinese gods and you know why
they urinated upon
one of these people is because they said
don't you muslims wash yourself
before you pray wash yourself with this
and so the the the the stories coming
out of the camps
from former concentration camp detainees
that made it out
because either their husbands were were
citizens of other countries or they
themselves were dual citizens
um are very horrific and right now
it is estimated anywhere between one
million to about seven or eight million
people in these camps
or have gone and left these camps these
camps
um whether it be the concentration camps
which mainly
is for torturing um indoctrinating
um and creating chinese people because
one of the reasons why actually the main
reason why we
support in these camps is because we are
not chinese enough
we are not assimilated enough okay
so what i mean by assimilation is so for
example
you guys living in i assume you guys are
in canada or united states
right so i i'm in australia so what what
they mean by assimilation is
because i'm muslim right i don't drink
i don't eat pork i don't free mix right
but the australian government is not
going to lock me up
because i don't do those things right
but for china not drinking not eating
pork
saying salam teaching your kids the
weaker culture teaching your kids islam
walking the way you walk eating with
your right hand
saying statements like my brother don't
do that that is haram
do this that is halal statements like
this
is seen as separatism is seen as extreme
right so so that's what we mean by
assimilation
obviously we as uh citizens of the
various countries in the west
we do not you know you know call for
violence in any of the lands as long as
we do this we are okay
but but but the normal things that we do
is is considered to be part of that
culture
whether you're a british muslim american
muslim australian muslim
so china you has been using this uh
this sabbath this reason of terrorism to
lock up
millions to millions of people it's not
to say that we have a few bad apples
in each population there are a few bad
apples but you don't see
for example you had fighters from the
united states you had fighters from
france and belgium
you had fighters from really go to syria
but you don't see those governments
locking up the millions also
or the thousands of muslims that live in
those countries if there was any reason
to lock them up those countries would so
china has been using that as an excuse
to lock up wigas willy-nilly and another
excuse that they use is that the uyghurs
are
some they're not educated or they're not
culturally
um you know that that they're like
barbarians
right that's how they see is but the
people that are going into these camps
are people that have actually worked for
the government they have been communist
members
they have they have propagated for the
communist party for 20 30 40 years of
their life
uh people that were already retired
getting
a communist pension or that were about
to
retire people who are actors singers
comedians
footballers people who are rich they
knew the chinese language they knew the
chinese law
and they still know the chinese law and
so
up you know besides this you you saw
the um you know the demolition of
mosques
demolition of churches now china is not
just against muslims
they are against every religion so
christianity judaism they do not allow
for the practice of the new age
religions
so you know the various new age
religions out there
and even if i mean there are still
mosques there there is still
christianity
but it has to be state sanctioned and
what they will do is they will take
verses of ayats
they will take verses of quran or hadith
and manipulate it in a way
to use it for their own propaganda other
countries do that as well
i've seen that but china take it to
another level where they're actually
mistranslating or rewriting the verses
of
al-quran and um and
just two or three days ago you guys may
have read of the bbc report of systemic
rape
so right now these camps are not just
used for indoctrination
there are the labor camps where they
where they make the biggest brands in
the world
pretty much every single brand from your
apple to your knife to your adidas to h
m to anything and everything somehow
even from
our heinz ketchup even that comes from
there
80 percent of china's cotton 80
of chinese cotton comes from east
turkestan so most likely if you're
wearing anything made in china
it most likely came from a uighur slave
and right now in the united states there
is a bill
called the uyghur forced labor bill uh
weaker force prevention
labor act to sort of stop this and at
least stop
the the dealings or the importation
of those goods we see china profiting
now
it's not when we compare the jewish
holocaust with the weaker holocaust now
the jews were
totally eradicated in gas chambers but
with china
they take it to a level where they they
benefit
off the backs they benefit of the slave
labor they benefit
off the hair so you would have really
reported about
13 tons of hair seized at the u.s border
how many people's hair how many people
are in these camps
where you've got 13 tons of hair from
one shipment
right and wiga's hair obviously
islamically it is not correct but
the wigan like with within weaker
culture
the way that the women braid their hair
depending on how many braids they are
it's culturally significant whether
they're married or not where they're
divorced where they're widowed and
mean certain things so we the women and
not just we women just
women in general don't shave off their
hair
unless you know there's a very very good
reason for it we have
also a situation where from the bbc
report where
rape is sanctioned and it's systematic
and in that report it tells us that
plain globe
meaning people from the outside are
paying good money to get into those
camps
to be sexually
you know with those weak women and there
are
there there was a testimony of one
kazakh woman who was working there as a
cleaner
who had to strip the women tie them to a
rope on a bed and clean them up
afterwards
and these men were paid so we see
another aspect of the camp as
being turned into brothels
state-sanctioned
brothels for the other women either who
are
out of the camps or who are trying to
prevent their family members
from going into the camps they sign up
to get married
to han chinese men and these time
chinese men
are generally people that work for the
ccp that they are
rewarded they are rewarded like our
women are given as
renima to the chinese men and this is to
dilute
the weaker blood because islamically
you know you know a non-muslim a muslim
woman does not get married to
a non-muslim but besides that
even if we didn't look at this from a
islamic perspective the forceful
marriage of anybody
is you know it is wrong and
the the children of the people in the
camps are themselves
just like what happened to the jews are
sent to boarding schools to be
indoctrinated so it's not a matter of
simply just killing off the uyghurs
like a rwandan style massacring it's to
make
the uyghurs chinese because the uyghurs
look like me
the uyghurs look they don't look chinese
at all simply the wig is being there
looking the way we are eating the eating
what we eat
saying what we say praying how we pray
is to extreme is separate
it goes against china's status quo
and china does not like difference even
though
it boasts having 56 different
nationalities
a good 50 of those have been diluted or
have been
part of the greater chinese society
but groups like the uyghurs tibetans
mongolians
and a few others have kept their culture
and kept their religion and
this is seen as a threat and because
we're still there
the the reality of an independent state
can become a reality because we're
physically there and so they're trying
to get rid of that
um yeah that's pretty much in a nutshell
what's been happening
so yeah
subhan allah the the amount of new
information that i've gotten
in the past however long it's been is
actually insane like it's
it's it's it's so heartbreaking that
no like people know about it but like i
feel if everybody knew about it to this
extent they'd be a lot more heartbroken
over it because we hear about
concentration camps but to actually hear
what's you know going on inside of it
reading that bbc article i couldn't even
make
it to the end i couldn't even make it to
the annual lunch
well as this thing it's been talked
about on mainstream media
but again there seems to be a disconnect
people are not reading mainstream media
um i believe it has to get to a stage
where
it's you know people can take it in for
example whether it be in movies
whether it be in um you know
whether it can be addressed directly uh
in popular culture that's not happening
enough
uh it's not happening to a stage where
for example the politicians are acting
on climate change because there are mass
protests every day about climate change
so it's not to that level yet even
though it's talked about your bbc's your
wall street journals your new york times
um but but again talking to channels
like yourself
talking like and then from here family's
talking about
it and then acting on it you know
especially if you're in a university
setting talking to
your professor so that sort of that
people action is still missing
or if there's not enough happening of it
um
yeah the prophet salallahu he said that
when a person sees wrong or injustice to
change it with their their actions
and if they can't then change it with
their tongue with their mouth and if
they can't then at least hate in their
heart
and what our brother is saying
essentially is
you see you see injustice you see the
wrong or you hear about it
if you can't do anything about it
physically then change it with your
tongue
word of mouth spread the news let people
know make people know send them this
podcast send them
um what's the name of the the talk east
turkestan right on facebook
send them that page send them the
articles on al jazeera send them the
interviews and everything send them this
interview
the interview he did with hamza zortzis
pass it along don't don't hold this
information this is actually an
imanna from allah the fact that you've
even heard about this
and now allah is entrusting you to pass
it on to to
make people known just imagine just
imagine you or your family in that
situation
on the day of judgement do you think the
these people are going to say
you know it's just the chinese people
that did this that's it no they're going
to say there there's an entire ummah
there's an entire muslim nation that was
supposed to be backing us and they
weren't there
and it's vile yeah and even for the
longest time we've been saying that you
know what you guys have to stop or the
west has to stop this
um even by force they've done it in the
past
um and i've talked to many and you you
know you know
when we muslims talk about force you
know we're automatically labels
terrorists
no people i've talked to many american
white professors i've talked to people
in the american military
they're talking about you know what
force has to be an option
and and this the weak option uh with the
weak apply is the
only topic in in the west at least
where the left the right religious
irreligious
atheist jews um even
enemies of islam islamophobes are saying
this is wrong
we need to do something about this so i
i know
you know muslims are afraid sometimes to
speak up their mind for
for what's happening within certain
muslim groups so for example
palestinians or
indians they fear they're going to be
labeled their feet they're going to be
attacked by their own
governments but no you will actually be
celebrated you'll actually be promoted
when talking about the weak issue so
again this isn't a manner
because a lot of the people you i i
presume listening to this channel
uh are from countries who their parents
came from
who themselves would have been
persecuted if they continued to live
there
so you yourself being out in the west or
out living
freely why did allah put you in that
situation there is a reason
you were asked about what you couldn't
do allah subhanahu wa
i've talked to many sheikhs where i
asked them will the will will the
weakest be asked about
and i told them to base it on evidence i
said well the will the world
with the will the weakest be asked about
that about that
their five daily prayers their fast they
said no they won't be asked about this
because they simply can't do it because
the moment that they in the camps one of
the former concentration camps what uh
detainees were telling me
they were telling me that when they were
sleeping their hands had to be
out of the blankets that they cannot
have their their hands tucked into the
blind
you know why because the guards thought
if their hands are going to be inside
that they're going to be doing zikr
but we know that you can still do
thicker with the heart but that physical
with the testes with the fingers
they thought they wanted to even stop
that
in in what happens in the indoctrination
is that the teacher who is teaching and
what they teach
is that that there is no god that there
is not allah
and that your god is [ __ ] and every
morning
the the detainees have to write letters
to xi jinping
essentially it is a dua to xi jinping
to set to repent to xi jinping to make
toba to xi jinping
xi jinping the leader of china because
that they had
that they had made tawba to allah and
that they would no longer make
tawba to allah that's you know what they
learned was incorrect and every time
each class finishes on their way out
they ask them is there allah
what are you going to say in that
situation you're going to say no next
person is there allah
and any person obviously you're going to
say no but if you hesitate for a second
if you go is that allah and you wait you
get beaten for that hesitation
so every little that there is no there
is no
room for rebuttal
there is no room for protest
in any way so people go well why don't
they protest why don't they fight why
don't they do this why don't they do
that
well you can't fight because you can't
get weapons in
geographically if you look in the
guinness book of records east turkestan
is the furthest geographically away from
open ocean
you've got nine of the 10 highest
mountains surrounding east turkestan
uighurs wanted to escape you can't
escape if you are to escape to the
central asian countries
they'll simply sell you back we have
seen this documented pakistan
they'll sell you back if you go towards
southeast asia thailand and cambodia
will sell you back
uighurs are not given passports even if
they want to leave
so many people say oh look at our syrian
brothers they are fighting they're doing
jihad
okay they can because you can get
weapons in and they can leave
from north they can go to turkey they
can get support they can get refugee
but no you're trapped there's no way you
can leave
so it is such a dire situation where
it is the worst thing happening in the
world right now without question
because you know many people sometimes
get upset with me
when i compare for example what's
happening to our palestinian brothers
and sisters and may allah subhanahu wa
really the situation but in palestine
you can still throw a rock at an idf
soldier
eventually once a zionist kills you
they give the body back and the people
you know say allahu akbar and they are
given a funeral
palestinians are not being forced to
speak jewish
they are not being forced to change
their names they can still speak arabic
to their children
they they still have hijab they still
have the beard they still can do salah
so a lot of these luxuries that even
oppressed
nations oppressed muslim nations have we
do
not have it's to that level
and for us and i've said this many times
places like palestine
i even spoke to mozambique and he even
said himself
guantanamo bay was a walk in the park
compared to what's happening to the
weakest
because he was housed with uyghurs in
guantanamo bay
and that's what the that's what the
uyghurs said
from guantanamo bay that guantanamo bay
was like janna for them
compared to what's happening in chinese
concentration camps
because in guantanamo bay
the the guantanamo of the former
guantanamo bay
prison prisoners they were saying that
they had quran in their cells
that they could fast that they could
pray that
they had beads what more do you want
subhanallah
and like you think about the prophet to
and he was he was an activist simply put
so we can't be out here not taking
action so we're going to get into that
in a bit insha'allah like
what we can do as individuals what we
can do as uh people that are in
universities
in institutions but i had a quick
question about what you said before they
they seized 13 tons of
of hair what were they what were they
doing with that well the hair
is is basically for um the women like uh
wigs
so so they get real hair you know you
can get wigs with real hair now
extensions it's for profit so they sell
it
um the last figure i got from radio free
asia that they were made in 2019
they made 1.8 billion dollars just off
the hair
and we're not talking about organs yet
there is a situation
uh called halal organ harvesting
google it right now halal organ
harvesting where
and this is advertised by chinese
hospitals
to invite middle easterners because they
opt for halal organs they opt for
organs who from uyghurs because we as
muslims we don't drink we don't smoke
so it's clean you know they think about
these things apparently
and as i mentioned in these hospitals
you know that china demolishes mosques
demolishes
like the word halal has been removed for
all restaurants
in these hospitals where they cater to
the middle easterns these rich gulf
nations
they have mosques and they have muslim
canteens in the hospitals
but on the outside mosques are being
demolished
so this is all over youtube you can't
you can't it's not just hearsay like the
chinese themselves
promote it on their websites and their
videos um
and yeah okay the first question i want
to ask you
is why are muslim countries in silence
right now
uh well one uh muslim countries in one
way or another
are oppressive themselves number two
um many of them are they've left the
deen
and i don't like to use the term muslim
countries because that would imply that
they themselves
are ruling by the sharia i like to use
the term muslim majority countries
and so china before they open those
countries
before they open the camps anywhere
between 2012 to about 2015 they went to
those
majority countries made dealings um
especially with countries like saudi
arabia muhammad bin salman which he
visited
made multi-billion uh dealings with
china um whether it be their own
infrastructure because
to to increase in trade to increase the
roads to increase anything economically
financially
uh they opted for china because they
were the cheapest option
when compared to europe and the west so
that they
so they bought them and not just that
they're silent they are actually
supporting
so they have been various letters
written to the u.n
where a lot of the signatories are
muslim nations who are
in support of um
china's camps so what what they do is
they'll pick
one or two influential people from
countries
in the middle east from muslim countries
they'll take them
to china they'll take them to east
turkestan visit the so-called camps
and you've seen some of these where it
does look like a school
where they're sitting down they're
wearing nice they're saying if you're
happy and you know it clap your hands
you've seen these clips
those are not the camps so they went to
these camps they saw
imams recycling quran so that they were
on what they called pump ticket
tours or stage tours of those camps they
went back to their governments
told their leaders there is no genocide
going on and they went about their way
and so if it was silent it would have
been enough
but they are supporting they're saying
china is doing the right thing
and what they do is china and the middle
east
say well it is better than countries
like the us
bombing afghanistan and iraq back to the
stone age
that's their rhetoric at least we are
educating these people but um
they're using that excuse but right now
it
is it does equip it is equivalent and
many jewish leaders
many jewish rabbis have said that what's
happening to the uyghurs
is what's uh is what happened to the
jews
and it's far worse because china has all
this technology
china has surveillance china has the
money in the influence they've
influenced every single country not just
in the east but also in the west
so we have things called confucius
institutes
which is pretty much in every whistling
university that there can be
where they it's a pretty much
introduction to china they teach chinese
language they teach chinese culture
and it's basically to soften the
students the university students because
that's how you get them if your
university students are getting used to
the fact that
china are a reliable believable honest
government that they could potentially
work with in the future
then those university students in 10 20
years
time when they become the leaders of
their countries they'll have better
relationships with china
and so there's this there's a push
especially in australia to get rid of
those
institutes because china used because of
the vast population
china is the most populous place for the
richest people and where the rich people
send their kids
to the west so and and they are paying
top dollar to be educated in these
western institutes
these western institutes uh the biggest
names
in of universities don't talk back
or they or they're not against because
they're afraid that they'll
that they'll lose all that money coming
in from international students
um yeah
okay angel rami do either of you have a
question because i want to ask something
that's going to kind of appear off
i go in okay man uh so awesome brother
so
the un the united nations who who's we
already know what their role should be
but forget it should and we know they're
deeply taught to the world health
organization all that
tell us about their what they've been
doing or their lack of
and you know why that's been stemming
the way it is
well as you mentioned the u.n was
specifically set up
right after world war ii right after
what happened to the jews
so what happened to the jews doesn't
happen again you know the famous quote
never again
but the opposite has been happening
where we've seen
especially in the past year or so
with how the world health organization
which is an arm of the u.n
you know backing um you know promoting
what
how china's dealt with covert same thing
happening with um
with uh with the un we have to remember
after
after the u.n was established the
winners
of the u.n were who america
england france russia and china
the big five so anything that does
happen or the anything that the un does
try to do
um is vetoed by china and or russia
number two we've come to find out that
um
i had the honor of interviewing a u.n
human rights lawyer
who was a whistleblower who who
she said with ample evidence that the un
gives names
of uyghurs who are about to speak um at
the human rights councils or the
meetings there
to the chinese so that they can apply
pressure to their families so that those
leaguers don't end up speaking at those
forums
so the u.n is giving out their names so
the u.n
not just with the weakest situation i'm
sure you've seen with
most situations similar to the weakest
they don't really do much because the
u.n is supposed to be a place where they
stop oppression
and do all these things the u.n was
established so that countries
don't take on that responsibility of
labeling things a genocide
so that countries don't take sole
responsibility of going to a war
but we've seen that in even in at the
beginning of the 20th century
21st century that the u.n isn't capable
of stopping wars
and the un isn't capable of actually
stopping genocides
so other organizations have had to be
improper
have had to be propped up like the
inter-parliamentary
alliance against china sort of a u.n 2.0
and other organizations
that have come up because the u.n is
simply not
doing what they were set up to do
um and so you've got countries like the
united states
putting their hand up labeling a
genocide other countries
hopefully are going to follow suit to
stop this
and we are calling for not just economic
sanctions if that doesn't work
now economic sanctions took place during
south africa's apartheid
um south africa was economically
sanctioned
they were they were sanctioned from not
being able they were boycotted
where they were not able to take in
world sporting events
um and that helped in eventually getting
rid of the apartheid government we're
calling for the same thing
and if that doesn't work to call on for
western military
intervention to take things by force
because it's not just uyghurs you've got
tibetans you've got hong kong
that that influence is spreading across
southeast asia
and we have to nip it in the bud
um and yeah and i openly call for
either a peaceful transition
economic sanctions or by force and we're
not wrong about this because this has
uh constantly happened and i have had
the honor of talking to people in the
trump administration
i've talked to people from the national
tea party and um
i'm not being attacked or i have not
been investigated
by my own australian government for
making such statements ever
quite the contrary i've been promoted so
um
we should not be afraid when it comes to
this yeah
100 i just wanted to to um elaborate on
the point of violence i feel a lot of a
lot of the time when people say you know
we shouldn't resort to violence
they're coming from the a very weak
position of uh perhaps we were in a
state of peace
right so we would all agree that if
you're in a state of peace you should
never result of violence
but if someone is attacking you and
you're now in a state of violence
then why should you be peaceful that's
if anything that's idiotic
exactly and there's ayat in quran you
know you have to defend yourself
you know if if your mother is being
raped in front of you if your sister b
is being raped in front of you if your
whole if your whole family is
slaughtered
naturally yani without even thinking um
you're gonna do what you're gonna need
to do simply for your honor
simply we need to focus us i mean i mean
like
what how much more we're just going to
turn the other cheek
constantly and and i'm not talking about
radical terrorist groups i'm talking
about western military
you know western supported u.n
sanctioned nato sanctioned
this is what i'm talking about 100
percent and if they can
hopefully that people don't
misunderstand and misquote me yeah insha
allah insha allah
if if the west can you know invade
places like iraq and iran and these
muslim factors and what that like what
the hell is their problem with invading
somewhere like china when there's
an entire genocide going on uh
i have one one question actually
somewhat related um
actually i'll let you decide insha'allah
but um my main platform is tik tok a
while ago there was this
this lady on tik tok i think she was
chinese item
and she was trying to call the entire
genocide like a hoax like the people are
just making this up oh this picture was
taken at this
conference or this little rally and it
was nothing violent and there's nothing
bad going on so
um what do you say to these people that
have evidence that this is
like an entire hoax and how do you
defend you know uh
our position on this well my question
would be
if i were to ask you a question does
does
a country like iran have nuclear weapons
i'm asking you guys do you think a
country like iran has nuclear weapons
they do not nothing like that they don't
have nuclear weapons and you know why
i and you can confidently say that iran
doesn't have nuclear weapons
you know why because investigators
foreign investigators un investigators
have had
unfettered access into iran
and what happens after that they write a
report iran has no
nuclear weapons to this day to this day
china has not given unfettered access
to the coronavirus the world health
organization's there
but it's not unfettered they can't go
wherever
they can't interview those doctors and
scientists who are imprisoned
they can't interview the ones that were
killed and
they are six feet under right now or
being cremated right
and investigators have not been able to
go into east turkestan
to investigate my uh foreign minister
um australia australia's foreign
minister maurice
uh payne has said let us in give us
unfettered access she said this two or
three days ago
china has not will not been able to do
this
and every time you guys can literally go
on to
youtube right go into wiga documentary
xinjiang documentary you know whatever
the journalists that try and give an
unbiased documentary they try and
shoot something right their documentary
ends up about how they were followed
by 20 30 20 10 20 black cars
how they are constantly blocked suddenly
so you hear this narrative
we we were going to have a visit to that
camp and
there was a mysterious car accident so
they had a block of the road
you know so you'll see this constantly
there is
only one documentary where one uh vice
um uh journalist was able to get in
she kind of had unfitted access but it
was still difficult you know why
because she didn't go there as a
journalist she went there as a tourist
and she sort of spoke to the people and
did this so
and in her documentary if i'm not
mistaken won an
emmy award for her work because she
risked her life doing that
um and so if the big question here is
if china has nothing to hide why don't
they
let anybody in i want to be proven wrong
what do i gain from this
no one pays me to do this i'm a school
teacher
right i work eight ten hours a day and i
do this whenever i have time
why on earth am i wasting my weekend
talking to you guys i gain nothing from
this i hope there is no genocide
i hope that there is no organ harvesting
but there is
you know if they're hiding something
something is going on
satellite images don't lie thousands of
witness testimonies don't lie
me my my family who are still
in east turkestan
don't have passports they can afford a
passport
they can afford to get visas they can
afford to travel
why don't they have passports they are
technically chinese citizens
that's a big red flag so all these
things
people need to think about people are
not letting
are being let in and people are not
being allowed to come
out subhanallah
that's crazy and if you
if you think about it and um if i sound
ignorant then it's probably because i am
ignorant to this cause but um
if you think about all these other
nations and you you
probably ask yourself was like well why
are they stepping in why are they doing
something
if he's getting to this point but it's
like
that would open up premises for war
because it's going against china and
it's like if
let's say the u.s were to go into
china and they were to free all these
people like
well that just started something
completely brand new
and like who knows what's going to
happen from there
yes so so most likely i mean the the
only way that this
could work in the most peaceful way is
to economically sanction
because if china cannot pay their guards
if they cannot pay their army
if they cannot pay that huge
surveillance and when i talk about
surveillance
we're not just talking cameras not just
cameras outside
one inside your house two ccp officials
living with you to monitor each and
every move
to to manage oh that person's eating
with his right hand
why aren't you eating with your left
hand these little things like any
little essence of religiosity is
they they can't deal with that again
they have a self-policing state so the
uyghurs
are reporting
each other to the authorities because if
they don't
and later it comes to be that fulan was
religious
then they're going to ask well you were
his neighbor why didn't you report him
and then you're also taken
so it's it's beyond just cameras and
cctv
that's everywhere even in the west we
have that but china takes it to another
level where
if you're suddenly if you've suddenly
got your electricity on in the middle of
the night
when last month you didn't ha and it's
the month of ramadan
that guy must be fasting right otherwise
why are you waking up two three four
o'clock in the morning
right how come you suddenly put 20 extra
liters in your car this month compared
to last month
so every little thing right
it's illegal for you to not have a
smartphone you have to have a smartphone
there was a period of time where people
didn't want smartphones
because there are apps that you have to
have on your phone where they track
everything
yeah so it's that there is no way of
again no protest and there's no way of
even like
secret protest where you're against them
because there is no blind spot
there are no blind spots you're you're
monitored constantly
[Music]
okay so if you guys don't have a
question i i want to ask or
um friday you asked earlier i just want
to bring it up again uh you mentioned
before you know we have to spread by
word of mouth um
and and kind of go to the the you know
lay men
and work the way up gain a population go
to the the politicians and go to whoever
we can
to raise awareness is there anything
else we could do besides educate
ourselves and others
is there like running a protest
even if it's not in china somewhere um
i don't want to give anyone any ideas
yet you know just just to be safe but
what else can we do yeah obviously um
whenever you do have rallies or protests
that you that you that you get the
necessary paperwork to do so
um talk to your mps um you know
go to your universities and see if there
if there are any relationships with
china
um whether it be in technology
surveillance ai
or organ harvesting like like medical
gear um look at that um
you know petitions you know there is a
call for boycotting the 2022
uh winter olympics um any sort of
project
even with your if you look around and
you see that there's chinese influence
uh try and find out why that is there
and um talk to your you know your local
members to sort of
um to challenge that see if your local
governments have relationships with the
chinese government because there are
governments that are
out there where where they're where
they're bribed and um
things like this um and
and the the most simple thing is your
presence online
facebook twitter if you haven't got a
facebook account get one if you haven't
got a twitter account get one
because that is our modern day weapon um
you know uh it's the
the more it's out there the more i mean
that the metoo movement
and and that whole that whole issue was
you know was off a hashtag
you know um and and and it's gotten to
such a level
um where you can't even say hi to a
woman anymore you know what i mean it's
uh
not not that you should you should be
loving your gaze but um
subhanallah like those little things
like for example give you one example
are you guys in the states or where are
you guys
me and romy are in canada and i was in
florida right
um in many states in the united states
you know
you know they've banned plastic straws
do you know how they came about
how that whole movement started you
either gonna have to have a middle straw
and you have to all you have to have
some sort of other straw
you know how that came about social
media
yeah but how on social media
i remember one there was literally one
photo
of a turtle who had a straw stuck up his
nose and it was bleeding
that one photo and people started
sharing it and hashtagging blah
and now you can't use plastic straws
anymore
so so so don't think oh you know what is
this you know
allah will ask you what you did within
your capacity it's like the story of the
ant the ant could
can carry only like a mere droplet of
water to put out the fire to save
ibrahim
that allah is not going to ask him why
didn't you grab a swimming pool
right allah will ask you you know did
you i'm not
i'm literally not joking and allah knows
how he's going to judge
but you will be asked about how you used
with the tools at your facility how you
went about that
you know if you could have done
something if you could have retweeted if
you could have shared if you could have
written a post
and you didn't yani so
[Music]
that that could make a big difference
and and
i mean we talked about the west did we
not see
french muslims being persecuted to a
certain extent
recently and they will call for boycotts
right don't think that this is not going
to be at your doorstep
many countries are looking to china to
see how they dealt with their muslim
situation
it's no joke this could end up i don't i
what happened recently i personally
don't blame trump for the half a million
people that died
of covert i blame china i don't blame
boris johnson for the hundred thousand
english people that died in the uk of
coburn
this is coming to our doorsteps
if you only knew who expected that two
million people would die
from a virus that came from china a year
ago
i i was talking to a bbc reporter
on bbc radio in
november 2019 and he asked me what
should we do i said we should boycott
chinese goods and the guy almost laughed
in my face
but what happened six months later
western companies were leaving china
people were you know investing out of
china
and they realize hey you know what we
actually don't need china we can
you know we were so dependent um on
china that you know
we actually don't really need them so
[Music]
as i mentioned with a bit of history
lesson it was the west that
made china who they are you know they
got rid of their enemies for them they
got rid of japan and they got rid of the
nationalists
and the ccp were able to establish
themselves
they've been appeasing the china
where they've got them to such a stage
where they can sort of almost
topple they can sort of take over the us
with its military and economic power um
and now you know it's they've created
this monster and
we can they have to get rid of it or we
have to be part of the framework to get
rid of it
and i am not against even muslims right
when you make dua
and this is not kufr what i'm saying
make dua for the u.s to do this
because didn't the prophet sallam make
dua for a room to take over the persians
so make dua to allah and
you know facilitate any tools tools that
you have
to do this
so question i know that uh
china is communist
what's the main religion that they
follow over there
uh they don't follow any religion number
one they are not communists
uh they themselves label it with
communists
with uh chinese characteristics and what
that means is
first of all in a communist state or in
a socialist state
the state would take care of its
citizens if they don't
there there are very few social um
advantages that you can have besides
free schooling
and um there's no free
hospitals there's no free um everything
else is paid for so it's a very much
capitalist society
with slave or minimum wage labor and it
and number two the chinese communist
party isn't actually
chinese because the first thing that mao
zedong the guy who killed 45 plus
million people
won he got rid of the chinese script or
he simplified it
the traditional chinese lettering or the
characteristic or the characters that
you see
that is written or that is used in hong
kong and taiwan
is not like the one that they use in
mainland china it's a simplified version
of it
it is sort of if i were to compare sort
of
fusa arabic and normal sort of daily
arabic
sort of that but worse because you still
got arabic
right or you you know you know the the
arabic used in al quran with all
its dots and you know with everything to
that simplified arabic
and he introduced latin what they call
pinyin chinese
right number two he got rid of
every essence of chinese culture your
scrolls
the various religions so there was
taoism
various forms of buddhism he got rid of
all that
burnt down temples
the the main religion in china is
atheism
but they have islam with chinese
characteristics
they've got judaism with chinese
characteristics and they've got
christianity
with chinese characteristics and any
other religion
is illegal so they had something called
the falun gong
in the mid 90s and you if you type in
far long into
google with organ harvesting they were
also put into camps they also had their
organs harvested
and it was pretty much like a
buddhist-style new age religion
so any of these new religions out there
is not it's totally
illegal and they had pictures of
uh xi jinping in mosques right in
mosques
in front of mosques in mosques um
and so those that do come in have to
realize that they're praying to
him and it's not um
it's not la illah
yeah this is the difference between
secularist countries like what we live
in and communist places
because secularism you mentioned it
before brother but
secularism is essentially we're removing
the state and religion right so you can
practice religion but it has no
influence on the state
politics economics laws legislations
nothing
communism is far worse than this
communism is like not only are you not
going to have
religion influence to stay in the law
you can't even practice it
you need to and it's kind of enforcing
their own religion in a way that you
need to
not believe in a religion uh which
forces you to believe in a universe
without god and
bring no purpose to your life and that
state is as muslims that's the worst
state
that we can be in yeah
and i say this and this sort of goes off
on a tangent
um but i'm sure muslims who don't
practice are watching this right now my
brother or my sister if you're watching
this allah subhanahu wa
put you in a country where you can pray
five times a day fast have a beard where
hijab and practice go to hajj
right and if you're not doing this like
as i mentioned insha allah will not
ask whether or not a uighur prayed
because he's not able to
but you're able to and you don't so
that's also a lesson for us
spiritually as well
yeah subhan allah i was actually
thinking about it during this podcast
like
how many of us kind of lose our focus in
in our prayer we don't really you know
we take it for granted we treat it like
a chore not like a blessing
and we have our beautiful brothers and
sisters the uyghurs who
are literally being persecuted for one
departure allah and
obviously they would do anything to be
able to like
like they used to yeah
wow man it's
and as i mentioned no um no i mean like
if we go back to the the palestinian
situation or any other situation
no palestinians are being forced to
marry jews
yeah you know forceful marriage um
their kids being taken away so
as i mentioned economic sanctions or um
forceful means and you know do your bit
do your bit on social media
you know um and and as you've seen you
know we've seen recently um it was a
game stop
you know that they took at the stop i
mean there's certainly you know these
movements of social media it
there's no for example in the rohingya
no yeah rohingya what happened with
unsung yuki right
what's the first thing they did after
the coup they blocked facebook they
blocked twitter
yeah because those those are powerful
tools
that they know what it'll do to the
people
and right now um that's why facebook
twitter youtube vpns
are banned in china why are they banned
because those things
are powerful they will influence the
people
so and you and and you've got these
weapons and you don't want to use them
or use them properly yeah
subhanallah what if we um and people
might have already done this
but what if we wrote like a uh like an
email template or something
to forward to or to to pass on to like
an mp
or any um a person with
political power or leverage in any way
because the first thing that i think is
if i'm going to reach out to these
people what am i going to say
right and it's a bit burdensome so what
if we had like an email template where
they could put their name
read through obviously and designate who
it's too and then send it themselves as
an individual
yeah that has been happening uh that's a
great idea and we can continue to do
that
um but uh the issue with that is how
many people are actually gonna do that
so feeding that information to the
people
number one have them believe in it
and be firm in their belief
and i liken this to you is a sort of
islamic channel right
that's what i gather right it's just
like when an islamophobe
right comes up to us muslims
and go your god isn't real right and
they say
certain things you got a moon guard and
why do you guys fast why do you guys not
eat pork right
what's going to happen if you don't have
firm belief in allah
right you're going to be sort of you
know what this guy might be right
right you know what i mean so educating
the people
and letting letting them have that firm
belief and so when
when chinese propaganda or things like
on tick tock where they go
um because china's propaganda is they
spend one so
billion millions and millions of dollars
on their own state propaganda
then we have something called 50 cent
media
trolls right or the 50 cent media
chinese army you can literally see this
where they pay trolls to write comments
to spread
to flag your video and i'm sure from
this day forward
if you guys continue to talk about this
your videos your tweets whatever your
postings will be flagged
i'm pretty sure this video will be
demonetized
um because of what we're talking about
um
and so and you watch the comments you
will have trolls on this
and go and they'll give you articles in
this so unless your followers
are firm in their belief that this
genocide is actually happening
that's not going to happen so one
education and then you can go ahead and
even do like
the template and i mean you can do many
different things
and so yeah that
that's what's going to happen if you
keep on talking about this because i've
been on other platforms
where uh where it's just like straight
up just muslim platforms
and once they started talking about this
they've realized they've messaged me
saying oh look i've been getting a bunch
of these
how am i going to respond i'm like that
they're not real accounts they're
50 cent social media army accounts um
and it's similar to what happened with
the whole hashoggy case
where you had a brother in canada um you
guys may know him where he set up his
own
sort of anti-saudi people like um
social media army but he obviously
couldn't
um i think it was 80 000 or 100 000
saudi pro saudi um trolls
uh they eventually all got banned from
twitter they locked them because they
realized they were working for the
government
but that that does work as well if
you've got the funds to do so
yeah wow all right um another question i
have is
let's say me or anybody watching is
thinking okay i want
one proper source that i could go to and
read about you know about this even more
to educate myself
even more what's one or two sources you
would recommend
well one obviously follow us on talk is
turkestan because because
uh on tokyokistan we we share
some articles but mainly it's videos of
clips
that have been verified and certain
images
but for news articles number one go to
radio free
asia um and when you when you type into
google type in ready free asia and type
in the word
uyghu are and you'll see the various
clips
because those journalists themselves are
weaker
they are able to call in and get and get
direct sources
and talk to real officials police
officers
that they disguise um their voices and
talk in various
um tones from there
generally speaking other western media
get
they sort of broaden what they have um
so radio free asia is your number one
source and then go to talk is turkestan
to vary other sort of media or videos
because there are a lot of fake videos
out there
where they're saying you know this
chinese police officer is beating a
uyghur
those those those are very very rare
um there are other types of videos where
we you know for example
mosques being torn down and whatnot so
yeah those two sources i would
urge and another source the the uyghur
human rights project they
often put out academic reports of what's
been happening with sources and it's
very well sourced
um so radio free asia and the uyghur
human rights project
is a facebook page correct yeah and also
follow me on um
twitter arslan underscore hidayats
um and so i do my postings and other
rants on that and
on toki sirkistan we also do interviews
um of anybody anybody and everybody
who's involved
whether it be researchers whether it be
prominent politicians
activists former detainees
anything in everyone's on our channel
yani yeah
okay we're gonna we're gonna put
everything in the description box below
above everything else so they can easily
find it and i had a question before rami
uh goes back to carrying
anyone that wants to financially support
this what can they do and where can they
donate
or you can donate to us but um yeah
but basically um as i said
we we generally don't get funding we
get we get certain donations here and
there
um but uh
then you can also donate to those
organizations that i just mentioned
the week of human rights projects um
and also the weak
american association as well
and yeah but your funding for us would
help us so it would give us time to
create more reports uh have us focus on
more interviews
um yeah that was a great question by the
way jessica
i don't even think about it because at
the end of the day like this stuff
unfortunately is not free obviously we
don't fisabili
but the reality is that there is a
financial
uh part to it and even going back to the
time of the sahaba and prophet
sallam you know the apostle to fund
certain things
to to fund certain reserves and to fund
mosques and all these things so
it is part of the the the ibadah part of
the worship as well so
a hundred percent 100 percent
subhanallah
all right subhanallah i'm like i'm at a
loss of words now
um i want everyone who who watches this
inshallah to share it to
at least one person just like think the
first person that pops in your head and
sha allah more just send it to them and
tell them to share it as well
um because this is the most detrimental
issue in the world right now and just
think about like this if if you don't
want to do anything to help let's say
you're lazy
you have me listening you don't want to
help at all the least you could do
to get your two cents in is just share
it that's it and in short little it'll
reach someone who is sincere and wants
to help but if you are sincere and want
to help
please first as a brother mentioned
educate yourself and once you
have sufficient knowledge teach that
knowledge and then uh
go to those you know the higher ups find
an email template donate do what you can
um and actually if you have any other
suggestions for them uh please let us
know now
um that's what i can think of right now
um
and just and and if you guys have or
any of your followers or whoever has
suggestions make sure you give us
because i always get suggestions from
others
as well um so you know allah may give
you ilham
you inspiration to come up with
something and you guys would share with
us and we would
uh reach and see what we can do to
to enact that insha allah insha'allah
do you guys have any any comments or
questions
i just want to say thank you for being
here brother
thank you for having me and um yeah
using your um
your platform i mean you guys are doing
what i mean there are channels out there
with um 1 000 followers millions of
followers and 10 million followers or 10
followers
it doesn't matter you reach out to who
you reach out to even if it's that one
person
even if it's your child you know what my
son this is happening
you know and your child may grow up to
be a human rights activist you know
because a lot of the activists out there
are not necessarily weaker we have white
activists
i i you know there are chinese activists
i mean
remember we are not against chinese
people
right because even the chinese people
themselves have been killed oppressed
uh by the by the communist party so
um various different people of different
nations
various different religious groups
atheists
i'm speaking to some atheists and they
have become
interested in islam because of what's
happening to the uyghurs
like like they were they were like
islamophobes
and even like for me from a tower
perspective just like
just some understanding though like it's
just subhanallah
how how you know like maybe they will
accept islam through this genocide you
know what i mean like
[Music]
subhanallah
words man the first couple things that
went through my head
uh obviously as you were speaking is
we're gonna put a big disclaimer in the
beginning of the video
one we're not gonna monetize this video
at all even if you know we monetize it
comes
it gets demonetized that's not even the
point i don't want ads popping up when
people are watching this i don't want
i don't want even one percent
probability that they see an ad and
they're like okay screw it i'm not gonna
watch this video
or you know because i do that sometimes
when i go on a video and there's too
many ads
i don't want to watch it right so i
don't want that two if
anyone that's watching this right now if
you could share it just like brother
ramy said to even one person
who knows it's just like that that
picture of the turtle with the straw
like brother arsene talked about like
you might share it to that one person
and eventually gets that one person that
makes the difference who knows and by
the difference i mean just
big pivotal mass globals change right
but you never know unless you try so
at the very least that's all we can do
it's all
yeah and it's it's not even just sharing
our video like we're not trying to plug
ourselves in we're talking about the
the whole issue and of itself like if if
there's something that you see
that you find compelling to share like
do it don't be afraid to do it
yeah 100 um i was just gonna say
it's so heartbreaking that people will
be so angry over
a turtle with a straw in its nose and
not this entire issue as a whole an
entire genocide
um because not only is like you can
argue the turtle issues done by humans
to animals
but now we have an issue of humans doing
it upon humans
not giving them any uh alternatives it's
just
like this is all you're gonna get
subhanallah absolutely the world we live
in
yeah unfortunately may allah protect
them and bless them all
and uh save them and destroy the
oppressors and save the oppressed and
allow us to be you know leaders for the
righteous and leaders for um
uh the rest of the world
i mean all right
thank you again for you so much may
allah bless you for all the work you do
allah like it's
it's an inspiration to me and i'm sure
the two brothers here as well and
everybody watching may allah increase
you and everything
allow you to keep doing this and and
make you especially
a leader for this for this issue uh for
the world aminyarab
any final remarks anything before we uh
close off here
uh just again um
you know bless you for the work that you
guys do as well um
and you know may it be a vessel for you
to get into the highest levels of jannah
inshallah
all right everybody one final reminder
share this video
right now share it to at least one
person two three as many as you can
educate yourself
reach out to those who you can and insha
allah together
um we can make a real change in sha
allah
and prevent um another huge mass
genocide from happening
before we're too deep uh into this mess
with that being said may allah bless you
all and our honorable guests here
masha'allah
aloha so
[Music]
fellas you gotta stop replacing allah
with
girls with women stop
using women as that placeholder
to collect all of your emotional
feelings your heart your
your love your this i'm not saying don't
love a woman and don't
don't be you know don't make them feel
good and don't be emotionally connected
to them but what i'm saying is
that little voice in your in your head
that little feminine energy that you got
because obviously as men we still got
that that tells you you know
i need this thing this this this place
of contact that i can confect my love
that i could just pour my heart out that
i could just share everything about my
day
that i could just give my soul to fully
why are you doing that to your women
when
your woman when women can't even take
that the right way when they don't even
know how to handle that bro
you might scare her off you might at the
end of the day look
women do that to us to men they vent to
you they come home to tell you oh
this is what happened at work see they
do this because at the end of it
they feel that relief they feel good
they feel like okay i just let i just
discharged all this energy that i had
and they feel more connected to you but
it's not the same way with with women
fellas if you go to your woman
and you tell her about this you vent you
do this bro it's not the same
what you should be doing is do this to
the most high to allah to the source
you should be on the prayer mat
on your knees hearing i don't care if
you're crying if you're breaking down
repenting venting showing all your
frustrations sharing everything
crying for help crying for guidance
crying for the blessings of allah
and it's like at the end of the day this
is the point allah is the point of
contact that you need to be letting all
of this out on
because at the end of the day i
guarantee you that feeling that a woman
has when she's done venting to her man
is going to be the feeling that you have
when you're done opening up to allah
on her name the
you can truly feel good and non-needy
and non-emotionally like i need to give
this to my woman
when you talk to her you're gonna go to
her you're gonna be more grounded you're
gonna be more cool you're gonna be more
chill
and chill sends that from you you know
what i mean and it's like
part of it knows damn like why can't why
can't i be that but it's like trust me
like women women say that but
they don't want that so at the end of
the day put allah first
make allah the thing that women look to
you
as obviously women should look to allah
before their man but you guys get what
i'm
what i'm saying for the sake of scenario
the thing that women need you as to be
that rock to be that thing that
they can be a storm around you gotta
look at allah
to be that so that you can be yourself
and fully let go emotionally around
yeah and there's nothing wrong with that
because allah tells you time and time
again my slave come to me repent to me
pour your heart out to me share
everything with me
so why don't you start having that that
scenario because girls are really good
at that man girls have
they have diaries bro they got the
sisterhood they got the friends on speed
dial
they're bro they know that we're open
energy systems like angel always
preaches and they know that they can
discharge any time
but as men we we constantly try to
repress ourselves because like
okay yeah i'll admit it bro no other man
wants to hear your issues we're not like
girls
but it's like allah is always there 24
7. here's the thing
you wanna you wanna hit up your homies
it's five a.m and you're like damn bro
they're asleep i know you guys know that
feeling
you can relate to that and you're like
damn how could i hit them up if they're
they're catching some sleep oh i gotta
wait till tomorrow so you cry yourself
to sleep or
i don't know bro some guys are hell
emotional but it's like allah is open
it's 5 a.m fajr is an hour away you
could pray to hajj you could do the
night prayer
and you could pray to allah allah is
never going to close his doors for you
so why don't you use that yeah man bro
so romney before you say something
because i i feel it i feel it coming
from you right now
um i
went through a period in my life where i
i tried to be more open and just like
talk about
my uh feelings and emotions
bro that does not work let me tell you
something
as a man there's a reason why we try to
hold everything in because
one when we're over here trying to talk
to everyone about it like
it doesn't really do the same thing that
it does for a woman
that it does for us but two
we can't fully handle it on ourselves or
by ourselves and that's where the
creator comes in
you know i'll open up a little bit here
with y'all and say that last night
or for the past for the past like three
weeks
i've been feeling real low
i've been feeling real low about a lot
of things but i didn't tell
anyone bro no one close to me did i tell
them did i share
this negative feeling that i was feeling
because one i knew was temporary and two
why would i want to bring someone down
with something that i'm experiencing i
just want to lift other people up
all right so i dealt with that i went
into prayer bro
and like dude i just broke down
in prayer praying to allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
and that to me was
the most relief that i've
ever experienced before because like you
know i haven't been muslim my entire
life like
i'm still new to this but like me doing
that
me being in prayer like you said you do
the prayer
you go to the creator you don't go to
anyone else you go to the creator and
you release to the creator
bro that's that's next level
and you actually feel like you have more
energy after don't you bro
because when we go to our homies
we don't feel that discharge bro we're
like damn bro let me go to another homie
well now let me tell this person let me
tell my mom
it's like when you go to allah you truly
feel done yeah
bro and it's weird because like when i
would go to my friends in the past i
felt exactly what you said
was like i don't feel that full release
maybe i need to talk about it some more
maybe i need to talk to my other friend
over here he's more into this stuff
he's more like uh more wiser and has
more knowledge and can really help me
out with these things
but man i'm being i'm being 100 my bad
i'm being 100 honest here and saying
like
whenever i would tell my friends that
bro i would feel
weak because i know i i knew that
subconsciously a part of them was
judging me
and basically seeing me as a weaker
version you know because i'm i'm
literally like
stepping down and being vulnerable to
this person but this person is not god
this person is not the creator
this person can't solve my issues this
person is just here listening to what
i'm saying
and by me doing that i feel weak and
this
bro like it never gave me the release
that i wanted
and it it almost made it worse
it almost broke like this bro the
feeling that i had it almost
made it worse and it's like i felt even
weaker and once i did it to allah
once i just stepped down and just
released it all to a lot it's like
there was no feeling of weakness there
was no feeling of
judgment there was just it was almost
like everything that i had
was just fully stripped away and nothing
but strength was given
nothing but clarity was given nothing
but peace was given bro and that's
that's next level
[Music]